would you suggest artists to stay
independent and just you know cause like
i'm assuming
at what point in time because if you
started in 08
i would say like at what point in time
were you making like real money off a
rap um
well it took a minute because it don't
happen right away
i was just talking to my bro neff
yesterday and he was telling me about um
he had checked his um dashboard at
empire and he had like 200
on it and i was like bro you only put
out one song yeah i'm saying so
i'm like it took a while like i used to
get my fifty dollars to go pay my metro
bill
right happy with it but the more i put
out i started noticing more money so
that's that's what the independent game
came from like okay man so i'm looking
at it like the catalog
keep moving yeah i'm getting at the dope
game like them like like the cds
is the dope now you know what i'm saying
so the more i put out the more money i
get
so it took for me to go up there one day
not to empire to a different um company
while back and i was they had to check
for me for five g's
wow and somebody i was with was another
artist and he was like uh
man how'd he get that like and he was
like man he got catalog he's been
dropping
he's been dropping so i seen that i've
just been on it
has that because i feel like it that
still holds true now in the streaming
era where like the more you drop the
more your spotify builds up
like you know what i'm saying like it i
mean
like my biggest itunes check like 75 000
that's crazy
that's for a month yeah wow like once
once it generates like you know it went
from
10 20 50. that's crazy
it was 30 at one point then it goes up
and that's when you get that call from
ghazi
and be like hey let me get this big old
bad girlfriend
you know what i'm saying